مصانع التصميم
تعلمك الشياطين أن تغني
يشرحون ما يغنونه
[موسيقى]
تأكل بين روح الآخر و
مثل هذا يتحدث معك مثل هذا
[موسيقى]
من ذلك الطريق
اللغة الإنجليزية
حتى التفاح
أذهب للبيض وأنا أحب
عذرًا للشهرة والتاج
تاميكا دايموند والمساعده
[موسيقى]
أوه
فظة إهانة
[موسيقى]
ا
قذرة بعض الشيء نفسه الذي يلعب
كما تم اكتشافها بواسطة الرياح
[موسيقى]
الأرقام عندما يكبرون قليلاً
12 سنة سأخبرك
[موسيقى]
وافقت على العلاج وعليه أن يعاني
عندما مت
يوم 9 اللعب
أردت أن أقدم يدي
أي نبات سيكون جيدًا لأي منحنى
ولكن عندما يكون ذلك جيدًا
[موسيقى]
إنه يعلم أن ذلك سيكون مفيدًا لي
يجب ألا نضع أيضًا
جزء لتكون قادرة على ذلك
لديك مثل هذا مثل يقول المثل
ميراث
[موسيقى]
من أجل إنقاذ الأجداد
للطب
[موسيقى]
و
الطب الذي يشفي العديد من أنواع
يمكن أن تكون الأمراض الروماتيزمية
يمكن أن يكون التهاب المعدة
يمكنك الشفاء من القرحة كل شيء
مرتبة للعلاج بالأدوية
طبيعي
أنا
ثم من الواضح أنه قوي عليك
ضع الوقت
[موسيقى]
الشيء هو
ضع كل شيء في مصلحة المرء
[موسيقى]
و
هنا كان عليك أن تشفي
[موسيقى]
هذه حقيقة غير مميتة لأنها تعتني بنا
يسمع
هو
[موسيقى]
و
أنا